you know I saw this from Politico and I
don't know if they're going to ban Tick
Tock but I personally think Tick Tock
should be banned for a variety of
reasons and there there is a there's a
difficult question but
you know we don't want to curtail free
speech
political reports will Tick Tock be
banned some Dems say not so fast the
number of house Democrats and at least a
few Senators remain unconvinced that
singling out the chinese-owned app is
the best course of action right well
we'll see what happens I don't know
exactly but let me explain to you why I
think this is happening I think the
Democratic party and the culture War
cultural left represent
zombification social zombification
zombies crave only to spread the zombie
disease there's no end goal so if you
look at the issue of tick tock there is
legitimate problems with allowing a CCP
product into the hands of our children
the cultural manipulation in China the
kids there are their version of tick
tock has educational science that kind
of stuff really great for our young
developing mind in the United States
there's young women who think they're
Birds saying they're a bird person and
their pronouns are bockbuck or something
like that there's the woman who's like
frog frog self pronouns these things are
being propagated on the American version
which is literally harming vulnerable
people to the point where you notice a
lot of the trans people the trans
species people people who actively want
surgeries are autistic and extremely
vulnerable Tick Tock is doing that you
then have the data spine component the
fact that Democrats would defend this
despite the fact that they are clear
obvious and objective problems with it
shows the zombification of the party if
it power empowers them they don't care
the damage it causes they want to
extract from the system so I think it
should be banned and the main reason is
not so much the data spying which I
think is a problem but the cultural
influence
we and that's probably why the social
zombies want to maintain it it spreads
social zombism and mental illness so
this is this is a big issue right now if
we want to win the culture War there is
a political and technological component
right here granted I think creating
culture is the number one way to do it
and pushing back but it's hard if the
mechanisms for delivering that content
are controlled by say the CCP
what's interesting is first of all I
heard earlier somebody mentioned to us I
mentioned the the fact that China has a
different algorithm for their version of
tick tock than we do right and somebody
said that Andrew Schultz said that he
started that as a conspiracy theory so
that was actually him that started the
stem rumor that they had that they had a
different version of the algorithm is
that even if that's true uh it doesn't
matter because the damage it's doing
here in America whether China was
getting the same stuff as we are not I
can't say if that's true somebody said
that to us when we were on the show
earlier uh I I think a lot of it's also
The Addictive nature of it as much of
the you talk zombification I talk the
addictive nature of phones of technology
and just how much damage it's doing for
people to have to use this technology
constantly all the time every day well
let me just say I mean uh you know if
Espionage uh isn't the issue I gotta ask
them what makes Tick Tock different from
what Tim's talking about than YouTube
shorts which is basically adopting the
same delivery system is Tick Tock highly
addictive short videos I mean
essentially
uh it's the same thing it's the same
product so why is that not a problem in
Tick Tock that's a good point and that's
why this bill that's been introduced
into the Senate it's called the restrict
Act is so dangerous because there really
isn't much of a difference in these
companies if you start generally
targeting social media companies for
doing or for people doing things you
don't like on those networks it gives
you carte blanche to just start ending
networks ending Tick Tock ending Twitter
we're Banning Twitter we're banning
YouTube because somebody on YouTube said
that the election was fake like I I'm
reading this bill it's called the
restrict act maybe we can pull this up
at some point and there's a few sections
in the restrict act that are completely
insane section three where we have
section uh three one C is insane
it's Section 3 A1C what it says is
oh my God this is so crazy dude this is
like the Patriot Act for technology
basically this is it cannot we cannot
allow this kind of what does it do power
it gives the Secretary of Commerce the
ability to
oh God it's so okay so let's see section
3A the secretary in consultation with
the relevant executive department agency
has authorized to and she'll take action
to identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigate or otherwise
mitigate
uh these Technologies is what they're
saying if they pose and undue or
unacceptable risk of interfering with
the result uh or reported result of a
federal election and they're saying like
if a person this is any any covered
transaction by any person or with
respect to any property subject to the
jurisdiction in the United States so any
American citizen that says an election
was fake on Twitter means that they can
go into mitigating any any mitigating uh
act that they can take to to solve that
meaning they could shut Twitter down I
don't think that Andrew Schultz thing is
true I mean the reporting going back
talks about how the algorithm is
controlled by the Chinese Communist
party so I pulled up Fox uh multiple
sources I had always heard that they had
said that they had a different algorithm
in China than we have for our version of
tick tock it was just something somebody
said earlier and I said I could see
somebody like leading with something
like that making a joke like that and
Catching Fires somehow there's no way
there was also reporting like two or
three years ago which we we talked about
so this is probably like two years ago
about how how they were specifically
trying to ban feminists and feminist
ideas from their from their schools and
stuff like that so maybe the specific
concept of Academia of stem content yeah
he may have made up I don't know I can't
I can't verify I don't know there's no
way I mean so so Joe Rogan made the
claim which popularized it yeah so
perhaps Schultz lied to Joe and then Joe
ran with it but there is previous
reporting that so that where people are
saying do yen is is China's version of
tick tock has a very different algorithm
that's that doesn't allow this kind of
content it doesn't specify stem or
anything like that though think of all
the influencers that will be out of a
job if they ban it here in America
what will they do but you don't make you
don't make real money on Tick Tock you
make like they push you towards brand
deals though right they a large amount
of following gets them more content with
other types of products that they sell
through their let me put it this way you
can make money on Tick Tock you can make
money on Instagram in terms of social
media I think YouTube is the highest
um like viewed a dollar ratio yeah and
it's still crappy podcasts are the best
audio version podcasts have like the
best CPM if you want to make money on
ads and sponsorships it's audio podcasts
Instagram reels actually do fairly well
for mid-level creators and down right
probably not for the larger ones because
there's a cap on how much you can make
per uh per month
Facebook does way better yeah so putting
putting your videos on Facebook makes
like 10 times the money of Instagram
yeah like per viewer it was weird don't
ask me why I don't know well Tick Tock
was completely worthless that's why I'm
I personally think Tick Tock in my
personal opinion I believe it is
probable that tick tock's followers are
fake
and intended to socially manipulate
young dude this is coming out of China
which said that Cove had zero covet they
were like we have no more covet now it's
all done like they just lie lie lie
analytically lie I think the one of the
the biggest black pills for me was in
somebody on Facebook like long before I
got rid of Facebook was like actually so
China's got the right idea by locking
people in their homes I'm like I'm
that's enough internet for today like
like somebody I've known for a long
period of time here's here's what's
going to happen there's going to be
another lockdown and then someone's
gonna make a video on Tick Tock and it's
gonna say I feel kind of bad this
doesn't seem like a good thing to do we
shouldn't be locking down
then the phone's going to go
and they're going to look and it's
people going to be saying that they're
going to get a bunch of notifications
from people being like this ain't it bro
you're wrong are you trying to destroy
the planet bro you're so off I can't
believe I ever followed you then they're
gonna be like oh what's happening why is
everybody mad at me then they're gonna
make a video and being like you know I
thought about it man like we probably do
need to lock down and then like like
like wow you're so smart you're so smart
that's what the Bots do Sargon posted
like a poll the other day that said a
bunch of people in Britain said when
they said like do you believe that the
the lockdowns were a mistake and most of
them said no
like I I don't know how big the sample
size was in a poll like that but like
even with hindsight being 20 20 it's
just you're living in a different world
than people of uh who intake a different
set of news to you so somebody watching
CNN or over there I guess the the BBC
they don't understand things the way you
understand about what's been going on in
the world so functionally they might see
the another lockdown is a good idea
because they just don't get that things
are different now straight up it's a
manipulation Tool uh Tick Tock we don't
have access to the algorithm so we don't
know what it's feeding us why it's
feeding us what it's feeding us we don't
know what's getting tracked with our
data so that stuff needs to be opened up
we need to see that code that I
understand we could use the government
to force open but to do these dumb Bland
General legal things where it gives them
they can they can mitigate any system
that quote poses an undue or
unacceptable risk to the National
Security of the United States are you
kidding me that is absolutely insane do
you do you use tick tock I have a tick
tock but I don't use too much of a
boomer sorry I'm on I'm on YouTube I
think I think you're a gen xer yeah yeah
exactly right yeah but it's like you
don't you don't need to see the code to
know that Doom scrolling is bad that
like you'll find yourself like 10
minutes go by and you're like holy crap
what the hell have I been doing for the
last 10 minutes and like I go through
phases like that right where like not
Tick Tock but like I there's a
difference between posting content and
then when you where you find you've just
been rolling and looking at nothing
important for 15 minutes you're not even
really engaging with what you're looking
at but you always feel worse for wear
when you're done and that's just as much
as you're talking about as it it
incentivizes people to act or promote
bad behavior or to promote unhealthy
Behavior it is mentally damaging for
your brain even if you're taking in
general content to sit there and doom
scroll for long periods of time what was
that thing called that you talk about
all the time apoptosis is that what
apoptosis when a cell programs itself to
die because it has no more function in
the system I feel like Democrats the
party of that right like every single
thing I shouldn't say everything but
like most of their policies are just
about killing their constituents like
abortion sterilization or now Tick Tock
it's like promoting the things that
maximize the likelihood an individual
suffers and then dies
that or just the fact that people who
use it tend to vote that way and it
encourages them to reach out to more
people that's what I mean like if their
policies result in people ending their
bloodlines they're like just basically
the Democratic party is the great filter
of social Darwinism well that's what
they talk about with lgbtqia philosophy
right they don't give birth they recruit
and then the people who are resistant to
those ideas have families and persist
and their bloodlines continue I worry
sometimes though like we've talked about
how they say gen gen Z is going to be
the first generation in a long time that
will be more conservative I don't know
if that's beared out to be true but a
lot of times I wonder it's like the the
power of social media you can have all
the kids you want that kid is still
going to have a phone at 12 years old If
the parents don't do the right thing
that kid's still gonna have a phone too
young and they're going to have access
to material that's very damaging them to
have access to if they don't have
parents that are showing them the right
way to live you gotta get out of the
Cities you gotta harmful your kids but
let's talk about uh some of the stuff
that we can do and pushing back it's not
just about complaining on the internet
like we often do so a few things we're
uh uh we did it we did a podcast episode
the culture War bill ottman was here
we're talking with uh James Lawrence
lawyer we are suing California because
California passed a law that has
requirements on big Tech platforms are
basically requiring censorship which
negatively impacts me as a media company
and and content creator for distribution
on these platforms and then Bill who's
the CEO of one of these big platforms so
we're actually taking the steps to do
something because we're not just sitting
around doing nothing we're likely going
to be entering litigation filing
lawsuits against
um band camp for terminating our account
because they've created a whole slew of
problems for us and all of the tens of
thousands of people who've purchased
music I think I think it may be in the
thousands possibly tens of thousands
so it's created a disaster you know and
the way we described it is like if you
if if you have like uh if you go to a
mall
and you sign a contract to open up a
mall store and sell a product and then
without breaking any of the rules in the
malls contract or any of the deal one
day you walk up and they've chained your
they've pulled the gate down locked it
shut they've changed the locks and
you're like I've got stuff in there and
they're like too bad it's ours now and
you're like yo yeah at the very least
you have to give my stuff back like you
can't just take my stuff what was the
reason they gave you what they didn't
give you no so so we don't even know if
they're still holding our money we don't
know if they're still Distributing our
content or hosting our copyright our
copyrighted Works without a permission
or profiting off of it because they've
communicated nothing so our only course
of action is going to be
if like that's what I'm saying the mall
analogy if they shut the store and we
know for a fact our stuff is in there
and we do because we had music on the
platform well so the first thing is yo
you have to let us in to go and check to
see where our stuff is we own the rights
that's our copyrighted work
with them all they'd let you go in and
say look your stuff's not there I mean
granted you know if you have an ice
cream machine and you didn't get it you
know it's there with us the problem now
is we can't contact any of the people
who bought from us
not directly so we don't we don't know
how to refund if they need a refund so
if they don't have the music then
bandcamp took a percentage of the money
that transferred and then
took the music away from the people okay
that's a problem because now we've got
to Pro like that that's like theft or
something I don't know that's
interesting and then if they didn't take
the music away now I've got a problem
because they're hosting my copyrighted
content and profiting off of it by
hosting it on their platform for people
without my without my involvement so
we've got a legal a legal issue that
needs to be answered by the courts
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time